all right Steven Steven where you from
urging where'd you grow up in good
company where England Englewood hospital
okay and you tell me about your family
you grew up with both of your parents
oh yes how how was your childhood
well done ask you've done this up kind
of messed up yeah I think I had a half
older sister
uh-oh uh-oh happen in the glory and Wow
didn't have the same mom but there's my
parents and it seems like my parents
were uh I'm sorry
my monkey got my father you poor is born
and I'd say like a me your sister hated
you yeah look yeah website and uh my
mother sought to uh she's here on some
luck redhead diner
yeah never okay there's a rare blood
type
yeah well suit certainly couldn't coming
for my family it was like a second
thought but that and they like always
seen a few there's a half-sister through
soup
so so oh nothing Susie apparently um my
next older on no LXE in succeed
see what would a jury when you left your
parents house when you Oh amen
oh yeah I'm gonna cheat on my follow me
for its board and it's older sister bono
very blood type O my famiiy optic my
mother
yeah Steven what what what is your drug
Elsie LSD how long have you been using
LSD amazing
Maryland
how long have you been using it oh he's
mine
I just this gene is ours it was no up my
mother taking off the intersect huh
I still got it how often do you use LSD
now uh I'm sorry heads up
I think melons I head up next is black
music on a gene and it was on I was on
housing [ __ ] we've seen which is
impressive IQs my African mother taking
LSD boom you know Steven when did you
first try LSD how old were you Oh
I'll heaven 7o think you were seven
years old when you tried it oh yes
who gave you LSD at seven years old well
then oh oh I like recycle tea
when did you first try LSD you told me
seven I'm not sure that's [ __ ]
awesome
nothing is vacuum in my and uh okay
because she never did I know however uh
hey Steve do you uh do you find LSD here
and on Skid Row
um you can purchase it here um no Monty
up on you I
well I had wasn't mine
and that's when we talked about your
sister before Steve do you have kids of
your own
do you have children oh I have to do
much but I'm 1000 you know sister not
Steve thank you for talking to me
excellent thank you very much
you